big news story President Trump announced
that he was interested in buying
Greenland and yeah that giant Island
that sort of northeast of the United
States and Canada and a lot of people
made fun of the idea but not me
I thought I don't know maybe that's a
good idea we need to know more right
right
Trump could have a good idea it's a law
of averages he's going to have a good
idea if he keeps having idea or sure and
maybe this is a good idea maybe
president Trump's on to something and we
should buy I mean the Real Estate's his
thing
sorta sorta and then so anyway I thought
is a good citizen I should find out for
all of us what's going on so ladies and
gentlemen this past weekend just a
couple days ago I just got back here's
what I did
I decided to fly to Greenland on behalf
of the United States to make sure that
this purchase happens and the whole
thing's on the up and up I brought a
camera crew and it's gonna be our new
Konan Without Borders special Conan
we just shot it editing it editing it
round-the-clock to have it ready for you
all for next Tuesday and I have to say
here's what I can tell you right up
front there are lovely people people
Greenland are absolutely lovely I really
enjoyed them it's a beautiful country
and I learned a lot and I worked very
hard on getting this deal done
Liz them and here's just a and and and
made a lot of friends here's just a
short clip from my visit to Greenland
what's your name look oh that's too many
vowels you've used you use every vowel
twice okay and what is your name since
you're just making up names my name is
Conan president Trump is trying to buy
Greenland did you know that do you like
that idea
what if Greenland bought America would
you like that you like that idea I'm
killing with these kids that's the best
do you want to come to Los Angeles and
be in my audience and just laugh at
everything they say do you want to do
that I will pay you just anything I say
[Laughter]
they're gray lappers in Greenland they
are really uniformly good lappers I'm
putting the word out to all comedians go
to Greenland you will get laughs be sure
to tune in for our Conan in Greenland
special airing next Tuesday September
3rd at 10 p.m. I was able to make
Greenland party United States to be fun